a
prominent doctor meanwhile in california
says he was
fired after questioning stay-at-home
orders in contra costa county before the
state mandate
he says the lockdowns did more harm than
good and caused needless suffering
pointing out a letter to county
officials health officials
the science is clear that more lockdowns
lead to much more
non-coveted morbidity and mortality he
joins us now
dr michael dubois blank was removed from
his post
as trauma medical director for john muir
health
doctor good morning to you and welcome
tell us your story what happened hi
good morning sandra thanks for having me
on yeah no it's been a it's been a crazy
uh
week or so you know a group of parents
that we were working with uh to try and
discuss
these issues with the county
was going back and forth trying to get
our kids back in school and
um the county was really not responding
to any of their requests
and so they approached us and said hey
uh
would you mind writing a letter to the
county to to maybe explain some of these
issues
all the data that that i'm aware of
looking at
children and the virus shows that it's
safe i mean there's many other states
now that have
months of of a track record showing that
it's safe for their kids to go back to
school
and um the state of california and
and the county is just not making that
possible
so you know we were trying to trying to
convince them
to get to get our kids back in school
and then there was uh some spin-off
questions that
you know were regarding small businesses
and
uh restaurants that were closing you
know these are
these are restaurants that are uh
you know just trying to survive and keep
their doors open
and um you know it's been very difficult
let me dig into two of the things that
you took issue with and that you just
mentioned there
outdoor dining for example yeah um on
this program we had dr gerard who
made a lot of news when he said yeah i
don't really understand that when
california shut down their outdoor
dining
he said the science does not show he
said he does not have evidence that
shows
that outdoor dining is a it concerns him
as a method of spread
of the virus um so he was pointing out
the science
opposite of what the state was and
shutting down those restaurants when it
comes to kids in school
that top health officials say that's in
some cases the safest place for kids to
be because
they're masked in their social distance
so you pointed this out
and then you've been let go from the
hospital did they
give you a specific explanation for that
firing
well it was it was it was clearly it was
clearly related
to the letter but did they say that i
have not had
did they provide that well you know it
was within a week of doing that
and uh no they they have not put that
down in writing but
you know that's pretty clear but this
really isn't about me and and my job
with with john muir it's
you know this is uh that that's a great
hospital they're doing
amazing things uh the doctors and nurses
there taking care of covet patients are
risking their health every day
they just got the first round of the
vaccine and let me tell you it's a big
relief
for them uh because they can come to
work with just a little bit more
you know confidence that you know
they're going to be safe
this is really this is really about the
community and how
you know we need to uh you know not make
this
worse uh this this is a terrible disease
i mean it's
it's killing a lot of people there are
excess
deaths and you know it's it doesn't need
to be made worse
there is a lot of doctors that are
questioning
some of these things that health
officials have very clearly said in some
cases
are not a problem the nbc bay area
says that they did get a response a
statement was released to them from the
hospital by which you were fired
the doctor is employed through an
outside contract it said and after
careful consideration john muir health
is not continuing
with dr dubois blank in that position
wanted to make sure that i put that out
there these are the county health
officials pushing back
on your concerns about the lockdowns
we'll put it on the screen
all of these orders have been based on
strong science and good data the doctors
are citing data that our health
department believes is not reflective
of accurate current thinking so based on
the two things we just discussed was
there anything
else that you wrote about or that you
showed concern with
where you differ with the known science
out there or the top health care
officials
at the federal level well i mean
the letter was written as a personal
letter and a simple email response to
some of our questions back to us would
have probably
been adequate one of the things we
talked about is the pcr testing issue
i mean pcr testing is a highly sensitive
test
but the specificity is not perfect
meaning that there are a fair number of
false positive tests
they're doing over 8 000 tests a day
in our county and just the false
positives alone
on that will put us in the highest tier
and and being in the highest tier our
kids can't go back to school
what are you suggesting is the false
positivity rate of a pcr test
well uh it's probably anywhere from
about one
to four percent uh meaning that about
one in a hundred tests might you know
that come back positive are
are is incorrect that sounds like a
pretty low percentage of false positives
is it not it it it is it's low but when
you
multiply that by eight thousand uh
you know the number is significant okay
um i'll just finish off with this up on
the screen
you're saying excessive testing uh to
your point just there
is what you're questioning icu capacity
you're pointing out it's been stable
since july first
you're also writing about hospitals
testing all incoming patients
captures more asymptomatic disease and
the cdc and pediatric societies support
opening schools to which we we spoke as
well doctor good to have you on here
this morning we'll follow up with you
did you have a quick final thought
nope have a have a good uh holiday
season uh
i wish you well thanks that's your
vaccine okay
when it's available to me i will thank
you yeah it will be soon